okay so about look at the right things
16:40 announced 50 minutes and 54 rolls
there's okay what do we think we've got
something great it
what does it 640 liters yes the heads up
I'd like to see ya okay I'll water heads
but not all of them here self can so on
therefore explain I mean we have some
work you on here we have no words though
can I get an explanation may be
wonderful it must rewrite it what what's
what's going on yes it is so three hours
in 25 minutes is 205 minutes yeah okay
so just pause for a second so that's
what this first line is right I would
have loved and I didn't expect to go
right away but if you have working I'd
love you to say something you like even
even just the word minutes right by the
way I think there's something missing
from the top line zero okay this is a
comedian gap for it so so just to say
like what is this number what is to
signify and you can is enough context to
work out okay three lots of 60 once it
says 60 plus it's 25 minutes that's
already bad see you 205 okay pick up
again yeah so it's for five minutes
seems okay good we just multiplied by
eight because every single minute that
passes you're getting a intravenous of
water so that's why we're plots of
playing these two together and just with
figure a bigger bigger that's what
you're not with after that amount of
time okay when you get to Part B now
I've got a question here about is a
capacity question we haven't looked at
capacity yet i mean not this year anyhow
you've seen it before we haven't looked
at capacity this year but this is not
really a capacity question is it I mean
it's got the weight capacity unit but
what is this question about what's it
really about - the idea behind it it's
about how time and this capacity this
quantity relate to each other right
where you have two quantities that the
quantities are measuring different
things like say liters and time what do
we call that there are two things the
bestower are but once we're there and
this is a rate when they're the same
it's a ratio yeah so this is really a
great question and so that's why we can
still tackle it all right
um there's an extra item I think we
could add here what would you put in
above before we get to this type
calculation anyone ok well let's listen
let's try and tackle what to do with
this now in just the same way that we
multiply by 8 here right because it's
like I know the type and I want to know
that the total amount here going in
Reverse right so I know the total amount
but I don't know how long it's gonna
take so instead of multiplied by 8
that's why the next step is to divide by
anything right so you can find this by 8
now what number does that actually give
that's okay right so 500 is a minutes
you're gonna take out you're gonna
divide through by 60 to get however many
hours you can get out of that and then
you've got some leftover minutes yeah
anyhow 408 it's it looks good yes what
look at everything looks less exactly
all right now lastly and this one's an
important one how do you get 254 rolls
heads up if you've got that outside yeah
all right I gotta say can someone
explain to me like some lines of working
that I've done yeah
sorry bro
my bad can we just stop resumed their
fertilizer you lastly are you so cute /
4 yeah right okay so if we divide this
by 4 which is you 18 okay so what does
that mean okay so let's just pause for a
moment because I'm actually going to I'm
going to take this idea with crunching
through these numbers in the right way
but I'm actually gonna sit out quiet
differently because I don't know maybe
you said that exactly like this but I'm
already getting a little bit confused as
to like what's what's my path through
here when do I divide when do I multiply
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
take this ratio here I'm gonna start
with this one there are two ratios why
is it the best start with this ratio and
not the other ones yeah okay so the
first thing is it's an easier ratio to
work with its own want to something or
something to water it that's a plus but
actually much more important to me is
that I only really know one piece of
like concrete information here which is
these 72 Pines that are aligned to start
with right now this is the ratio this
one two four one it's the one that has
poisonin do you see that the other ratio
doesn't have anything to do with pies so
you're gonna start here start with the
pliers that's always a good principle
life so here's what I'm gonna write
sandwiches two pies right so I'm gonna
write one sandwich and if you're working
out started differently to mine can you
just follow along with me one sandwich
two for pyres that's what this ratio set
okay now instead of dividing by four
again same idea I want to turn this
ratio it's a ratio that works with my
numbers okay so certain value by four
I'm going to multiply by something to
turn this
right hand side into semi two pipes now
we actually already know what number
that is
it's 18 right so I'm going to have 18
sandwiches you have 72 times does that
make sense you see I start with
something on you and then I changed it
now I've got the relationship continuing
so then I take this idea and I can move
to my next ratio right because now I've
got bread rolls and sandwiches what's
the ratio here three bread rolls three
minerals to two sandwiches right but in
fact we know from the previous line that
there were not two sandwiches there were
18 so what am I gonna do with this line
I'm gonna multiply both sides very good
so multiply this by nine excuse me the
18 that I wanted and then you multiply
this by 9 which gives you okay all right
so that's a great question how did I
know it was 9 I wrote this down the
question just told me 3 to 2
yeah there is bread he told me 3 to 2
but that's a simplified ratio right
there were much more than they divided
through by some number so what I did was
I base it on how many sandwiches I know
they actually sold which you helped me
work out earlier was 18 question now
he's the lovely thing about this right
here's a lovely feminist you can
backtrack through this you can backtrack
through and this is so important because
you don't want to do this is right
because I told you you want to know
what's right because you can convince
yourself of the answer now just like
back you know just like back in am 1
we're just solving equations right you
get an equation you get down to
something you like x equals whatever
number you like what do you do with that
number to check whether you will correct
them if you solve any question yeah you
pop it back in right so I'm gonna do
exactly the same thing here with what I
know to be what I think to be true and
I'm gonna see if enjoy
what the question said okay I think
there are 27 bread rolls and 18
sandwiches does this match the roll to
sandwich ratio they're giving me it does
right so okay just keep going backwards
through the next thing I think is that
there are 18 sandwiches to 72 pies down
to what check on a calculator does that
match the one to four ratio that their
sakes there which is two pies it does
and the only back one more step there
then telling their signature pies have
already got that I do right so I've now
accounted for all of the information in
the question okay now 54 you can see
this is not that far off what isn't it
that's a lot rod but it's only up by a
factor of two yeah or 1/2 right so you
can see this is not a crazy answer but
the question of well how did we get
unhinged from that to get to here I can
all those guarantees will people a sort
of circle or like how did you actually
set this out where did you choose to
divide or multiply and therefore like
where did your error actually creep in
and you know there are lots of different
ways to get this wrong because there are
lots of different ways to go to this
question